le petit village dernier ti et meurtri
et marquez
il n'ya que très plus d'enfants dans les
rues mais beaucoup d'aînés débattent à
des survivants qui n'oublieront jamais
le mois d'août 2010 8
médicaux dit que la guerre leurs atouts
faucher numérique est apparu quand même
la terre moins fertiles
comme tant d'autres villages de la
région est menée ti a été complètement
détruit par les bombardements de l'armée
russe elle nous raconte que les soldats
russes mais ont aussi volé puis ont
brûlé leurs maisons avant de se retirer
comme ils le font aujourd'hui dans les
villes d'ukraine on sait ce que ça veut
dire pour nous car leur ennemi juré est
encore si près
en fait il n'est jamais vraiment parti
sera les ocz la base militaire russe
juste lazio tard il n'y a que des
barbelés qui ne sais pas
nous sommes à 200 mètres à peine de la
ligne de contact avec le ceti du sud un
des deux territoires séparatistes de la
georgie que vladimir poutine et son art
me contrôler officiellement depuis le
conflit de 2008
la guerre haïti brève du meurtrier plus
de mille morts et cent vingt mille
déplacés en cinq jours de combats
ceux qui sont restés ont reconstruit
leur maison se distingue des ruines avec
leurs toits colorés aux tarby seul
anxieux
une carte de la région tapissent le mur
de son modeste salon il explique ce qui
l'a pris
si la russie gagne en ukraine où seront
les prochains ces garanties l'ukraine se
bat pour la géorgie pour la moldavie
pour la pologne où
il reproche à son propre gouvernement de
ne rien faire et de manger dans la main
de moscou pour servir ses propres
intérêts potard est à ce point des
goûters qu'il irait lui même affronter
les russes mais ses jambes le traite
ils vont être 2000 georget sont en
ukraine y compris son voisin arquette
sorte ab on voit sur cette vidéo qu'il a
envoyé du franc
arkadi est mort le 16 avril il avait 40
ans
léry et son cousin et nous dit qu'ils
devaient aller le rejoindre en ukraine
quand il a reçu l'appel et une photo
pour confirmer sa mort
arkadi est un héros dit il s'est battu
contre les russes ici en géorgie en 2008
je regarde tout le village est consterné
ils montent la garde devant la maison du
défunt parce que son vieux père est à
l'intérieur il n'est pas encore au
courant un nouvel veulent démolir on
attend que le corps soit rapatrié pour
le lui annonce un autre cousin nous
invite à boire un café le temps de se
vider le cas à lui atteint son quota est
quoi le capitanat au clash et
blanchiment des cheveux
si l'occident avait aidé la géorgie en
2008 l'ukraine n'aurait pas été envahi
aujourd'hui les georges et se sont
batiss
sommes interrompus par les chiens temps
quelqu'un frapper au portillon c'est le
père du soldat qui vient aux nouvelles
quelle tragédie on le lui dira le soir
mais
tout est fini on tremble de peur on a
pitié des ukrainiens et on tremble de
peur
qui sait ce que poutine a dans la tête
il faut l'arrêter diot tard
il a le champ libre d'autant plus que le
site du sud flirte désormais avec l'idée
de se joindre officiellement à la
fédération russe
la dépouille d'arcadie arrivé samedi à
tbilissi ceux de deux autres jeunes
géorgiens qui ont marché sur une mine en
allant le récupérer arriveront demain la
guerre est une saleté
quatorze ans après la sienne la georgie
se battent toujours
notre ennemi est commun la guerre de
l'ukraine et la nombreuse